am tag seiner fahrprüfung ist ein junger
biker auf einem motorrad ums leben
gekommen es war seine prüfungsfahrt als
in bensheim entscheidender und sich
drehender mercedes suv entgegenkommt der
nachfolgende fahrer mit dem pulver
konnte rechtzeitig noch anhalt mit
blieben unverletzt genauso wie der
ursachen der autofahrer fahrlehrer
prüfer und unfallzeugen müssen von
seelsorgern betreut werden
nun nehmen freunde und familie abschied
von dem 24-jährigen lassen luftballons
steigen
wir sind wie brüder aufgewachsen nun
einfach aus dem leben gerissen schreibt
ein freund auf einen zettel
noch wird ermittelt wie es zu dem unfall
kommen konnte sagen muss man das hier
die geschwindigkeit dieser kurs auf 60
km/h beschränkt ist als eben gefährliche
kurve ist generalistisch strecke hier
ist der unvorbelastet zum
unfallzeitpunkt hatte es geregnet und
die fahrbahn war nass fest steht der
fahrschüler hatte keine chance
selbst erfahrene biker hätten dem
schleudernden suv nicht ausweichen
können